No,
no,
I don't agree.
I people have been attacking Alan
Greenspan pretty vigorously in the press
lately,
and a lane.
The whole blame for the credit crisis at
his feet.
So what I think about that is it is two
things.
One is that in the 19 nineties,
Alan Greenspan could do no wrong.
He was hailed as the maestro.
Bob Woodward wrote a book called the
Maestro.
Um,
and uh,
Bob Woodward said,
you know,
at the end of the wizard of Oz,
when the man comes out behind the from
behind the curtain,
when the wizard chose his face,
we feel a little bit underwhelmed.
But with Alan Greenspan,
we always feel safe or something like
that.
I think they gave him too much credit
for monetary policies when times were
good because when times are good things,
when the economy is strong,
a monetary policy is really sort of
boring.
But what Alan Greenspan did and realized
was he just got out of the way and let
productivity drive the economy.
And,
but where the real test of a central
banker it comes is when the usual rule
books don't apply when you're not just
making monetary policy for,
for
ordinary times,
but where when you're subject to
some fundamental strains on the
financial system.
And Greenspan faced several such
incidents.
The first was October of 1987 when the
stock market collapsed.
Another was the Asian financial crisis
in the 19 nineties,
the Russian bond default in the 19
nineties,
there was the collapse of longterm
capital management and the 19 nineties
there was 9:11.
And in all of those cases,
Alan Greenspan understood what the,
what the role of the central bank was,
was to provide enough liquidity and keep
the financial system functioning.
And because he knew enough because he
did that in those instances,
he came out of those crises with his
reputation is enhanced.
And uh,
and that was his real genius,
was to know what to do when the system
was,
was in a severe crisis.
And for all those reasons,
the shocks that were felt than didn't
become the new normal.
So the charge against him is in lately
has been that he kept interest rates too
low for too long,
but when he left office there wasn't a
lot of inflation.
So there's a real question about what do
you mean by interest rates being too low
for too long?
It was not the case that he caused the
housing bubble.
Having interest rates low doesn't mean
you have to make unwise loans.
Nor nor did he encouraged people to
assume that prices could only go up and
up.
So I think he's a convenient scapegoat.